字幕: Takahiro Shimpo
校正: Masaki Yanagishita
皆さん こんにちは
こんにちは
ありがとうございます
ギタリストの安達 久美です
(拍手)
私は11歳でエレクトリックギターを
始めましたけども
それまでは
テレビゲームを一日中してるような
子供でした
ゲームは熱中できるし
その場面をクリアする喜びもあります
でも ギターと出会ってから
練習したことが
全て自分の身になっていき
ゲームとは違った達成感
充実感があることを知りました
世界中に仲間もいっぱいできました
そして 素晴らしいことに
音楽にはゲームオーバーがないんです
(笑)
(拍手)
今の若い人たちにも是非
その喜びを味わってもらいたいですね
今 私には
恐れていることがあります
それは 時代がせっかちに
なってきていることです
音楽においても以前は
一曲５分が普通だったんです
それが 最近ではもう２ ~ ３分しか
聞いてもらえなくなってきました
このままどんどん短くなっていくと
私がやっているインストルメンタルだと
イントロで終わっちゃうんですよ
(笑)
私の曲には歌詞がなく
映像やストーリー
そして空気感を音で表現してるので
もっと時間が必要なんです
今日 ここで
何を演奏するかも悩みました
でも 私は皆さんに
私の一番の曲を
聞いてもらうことに決めました
私からの挑戦です
私のバンド名にもなった
「パンギア」という８分もある曲です
（笑)
地球は昔
パンギア大陸という一つの
大きな大陸でした
そのパンギア大陸が
地殻変動を起こし
現在の５つの大陸に
分裂していくさまを描いた曲です
さて この８分間の地球との旅で
あなたは何を感じ
どんな考えが頭に浮かぶでしょう？
聴いてください
(拍手)
(演奏 開始)
(演奏 終了)
(拍手)